whole concept behind affirmations that i
do not like you know i'm a lion i'm a
tiger i'm a whatever right just saying
them doesn't make them true unless
you're a crazy person then what we have
to do is create something else which is
evidence we have to give ourselves
evidence that we are this type of person
in order to become that but how do you
have evidence that you are going to be
this person when you have none well it
starts with activity it starts with
doing the stuff what you do literally
becomes who you are which means that we
can actively change who we are by
changing what we do we need to take
action in order to do that and so i
think the simple and easiest cue that we
can use to change who we are to change
character traits that we find
undesirable is to simply ask ourselves
when we're confronted with the decision
what would this type of person do and
then act in accordance to that and i
find it much simpler than having the
lists and having the the daily routines
and the things like that because if you
are this type of person
you will do the types of things that
that type of person would do